the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and welcome to today's presentation
on order flow nuances and techniques to
improve your trading
my name is michael baltos i'm the
founder and trader at orderflows.com
so you know to start off this
presentation today i want to ask you
you know what is your edge in the market
do you have one because today i'm going
to share mine
with you and what you're going to learn
in today's presentation
is how to trade order flow the way
institutions do
how to get the maximum out of order flow
delta how to see
market imbalances in ways other traders
miss
and lastly i'm going to talk about how
to determine short-term value and how to
trade it
hopefully it'll take only about 45
minutes but i know some of the stuff
is a little bit in-depth so it might
take a little bit longer so i appreciate
your
patience and understanding
so those that are new to my presentation
you know let me just explain who i am so
you can understand where this
information is coming from
and why it's relevant so my name is
michael baltos and
for the last five years i've been the
owner and trader at orderflows.com it's
a company that i started after leaving
jp morgan i spent eight years at jp
morgan
as vice president of futures trading on
the trading desk
you know i wasn't sitting in a corner
office watching people's p
l and come over tapping them on the
shoulder saying hey
you know what you're you're trading
outside your limits no you know i was
the one there
banging away on the computer since it's
all computerized
uh doing the trading myself prior to
that
i spent four years at cargill also doing
the same role
but more of trading desk manager where i
had a team of traders that i was
managing as well as doing the trading
and prior to that i was with commerce
bank in chicago as a licensed
urex trader so i traded buns bobble
shots
you know at that time that was back
around 1998
99 2000 that was you know i was one of
the only of about three or four people
in the united states that
was able to trade buns bobble shots dax
euro stocks
on the ux terminal itself you know
because there was
when your ex came to chicago a lot of
the traders on the board of trade
started complaining
that hey you know what you're taking
away our market share but i got in at
the time when
you know i sort of grandfathered in
under that uh
under that under the company commerce
bank and prior to that edf man you know
global macro trader the big english
company
i spent two years there on the macro
trading desk and i started on the cme
floor back in the early 90s
and eventually i left the trading floor
when i realized you know electronic
trading was going to be the future of
trading
and i joined the globex trading desk you
know that was
the electronic trading desk for after
hours i literally worked from
10 pm until 9 00 am trading on the
electronic markets
you know we didn't deal with the floor
market so much
you know in europe they were still
trading the floor markets in asia still
trading on the floor but
you know our main focus was providing
liquidity
on the electronic markets at night so
you know what i'll be talking about
today is you know what i've learned over
25 years of trading electronics at the
highest level
in 2013 i left jp morgan spend more time
with my family you know
what is the point of trading if
you don't have the freedom you know and
working at jp morgan i didn't feel i had
that freedom anymore i was
literally tied to my desk i would come
in at six in the morning and leave at 5
p.m at night
i'm spending more time with my work
colleagues than i was with my family
so i started you know i decided i got to
do something i got to make a change so i
left jp morgan
to trade for myself and i wanted to
write a book on trading sort of give
back
things that i've learned over the years
and i ended up writing this 150 page
book and if you stick around to the end
i'm going to show you how you get a copy
of that book for free you can download
it it's
not going to be the hard copy you're
going to get a pdf that you can
print out and read or just read it off
your phone or computer
but like i said in 2013 after leaving
jpmorgan i was trading for myself i was
trading
with order flow on what i already knew
about the markets and order flow and
reading the order flow
and the software that was out there i
wasn't pleased with
in the sense that it was very basic so i
sat down with the programmer
around 2014 and i said hey you know what
this is how i look at order flow this is
what's important to me
in the order flow and can you put that
into the software
okay so i did that and i started using
it myself
and you know i was sharing it with some
people and people like hey this is great
you should
think about selling it and you know i
really i held off and i held off
and you know since it was created for
ninjatrader you know the guys at
ninjatrader
you know back in those days they had the
ecosystem um in a different form that it
is now
you know i got on the ecosystem and a
lot of other traders really liked my
software
okay and what it is is it's a volume
footprint chart
with seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators
already there right so you don't have to
sit there scratching your head
you know what does this mean uh you know
what does this mean in the order flow
what does what happens when this occurs
you know it's already there it'll
highlight to you
things that are happening in the order
flow and the reason i just talk about
this is because i want you to understand
the charts that you're going to see in
this presentation
are generated from that software and it
runs on ninjatrader eight
but before i jump in you know brief
disclaimer please understand that
trading
involves risk right so only risk capital
that should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading you know
don't don't trade with your rent money
so to speak
so the first thing i want to talk about
is how to trade with
order flow the way the institutions do
okay
and you know when when most traders
think
of the institutions you just think of
the big bankers right the
well what's jp morgan doing what's
goldman sachs doing
and you know that's all well and good
you know you got to follow the money in
the market you know this is just
um you know a couple weeks ago you know
goldman sachs
you know their earnings on trading bond
trading revenue
surge 150 to 4.2 billion
equities trading 2.94 billion
so you know jp morgan also
bond trade has posted a revenue of 7.3
billion
you know which is 120 increase from the
year before you know equity traders
uh posted revenue of 2.4 billion you
know the hedge funds got
true hundreds of billions you know
thousands
it was trillions here under assets under
management
um you know so the part that a lot of
people
forget about are the big oil trading
companies you know the big commodity
trading companies and i spent um you
know six or seven years
you know at those type of companies you
know at cargill at edf man
they are have a very big footprint in
the market
as big as if not even bigger than the
banks and a lot of traders
retail traders don't really understand
you know who these people are you know
vital is
one of the biggest oil trading companies
in the world you know
just this year they're paying six
million dollars to the top employees
you know like 300 people got over six
million dollars in bonuses
gunver which is also a big commodity
trading company
you know they're posting you know almost
like record profits
this past year and you could just run
down the list you know here's a list of
a lot of these companies vittel glencore
cargill coke
adm gunver trafigura mercuria noble
louis dreyfus bungie wilmar you never
hear of these companies
but these are very big companies and
they
they control literally the supply chain
of many commodities you know most of us
that are in trading you know we just
understand what you know what's the s p
doing what's the dow doing
but you got to look at you know there's
crude oil there's corn there's soybeans
you know there's palm oil there's so
many different commodities out there
besides just trading mini s ps or mini
nasdaq
so once you understand that there's so
many big players in so many different
markets you got to understand that you
can't see
who is buying or who is selling you
don't know if they're getting longer
getting short right
but you have to focus on what you can
see big orders being traded in the
market
so you know the volume footprint chart
in my opinion is the best for seeing
what the big boys are doing
right this is gold yesterday you know
gold is the the new bitcoin now
you know it seems ironic to say that but
you know gold has been
been on a tear for the last uh several
months
and this is just yesterday so this is a
quick 30 second chart and you can see
right up here at this swing high
you got a big order sitting up there you
know resting liquidity so to speak
102 contracts trade there what happens
market sells off okay now you don't have
to know who that 102 contracts is
you know you don't have to know if it's
getting in or getting out of position
what you have to know is
hey there's 102 contracts up there
that's enough to stop this move
up and push it back down okay because
what happens as the market's rallying up
it hits a resistance level
then when you hit that resistance level
can't break past it what happens
traders all of a sudden that we're
buying on the way up know that there's
resistance up there
they're going to turn around start
selling it markets going to sell off
okay so again you know this is gold on a
30-second chart 102 contracts
is considered big you got to understand
you know what's considered big size for
your market
you know and this is a nice move from
down to 2071. you know in a matter of
three minutes here's another
yesterday again in the gold boom we hit
the low trade 203 contracts
two ticks off the low you do get past it
you know you trade 10 lots right below
it trade another one right below it
but then you can't come back down to it
you know people recognize
that there is a big buyer down there
okay
and once you recognize that once you
recognize where there's
active buyers or active sellers in the
market for big size
then you know there's a big participant
there
who thinks the price is cheap at this
price you know on the previous example
there's a big seller up there who thinks
price is expensive up there
okay and so you know you can see how in
the order flow the market is generating
support
and resistance levels okay there's
market generated information
at its best and you could react to this
as soon as it happens
right you're not draw you know you're
not looking at a chart 10 minutes later
saying oh you know this is here as
you're trading it during the trading day
you can see hey
well there's a big buyer there you know
that someone just scooped up 203
contracts there
okay there's some absorption or there's
some distribution going on
and react to it instantly you know
that's where the power of order flow
comes in
right is recognizing what the other big
players are do
are doing and there's this common
misconception of size
size in the market you know
if you're a big trader okay now i'm just
speaking from my own experience
um working for you know big companies
trading big size in the markets
if you're a big trader okay and you got
a big order
right you don't want to move the market
okay that's just
how it works right because you know that
if you're buying okay
say you got a thousand contracts to buy
here at 2025
which is what this order was buying you
know probably 200 there
okay you don't show the whole i mean you
can show the whole 200
you know most likely you're going to
iceberg it show 10
20 at a time and you know that on
most trading systems and professional
trading systems
there's a function you know it's called
the iceberg right so you just put in
your iceberg order
you hide the size you know you put your
order in by 200 show 10.
okay and it just automatically reloads
reloads reloads
so as the market's coming down right
people are selling into that they think
oh my gosh we just broke 25
let's sell some sell some okay but then
the order keeps reloading
okay so they're not the big buyers there
he's absorbing all the selling
right people are selling oh sell it sell
it but the guy is just there sitting
back
yeah i'm just taking help i'll buy
whatever you guys got
but if he were to show his full size you
know 200 contracts
you know the market might come down to
20 25 then traders will start noticing
it in the order book
and they might might react off of it and
say oh my god i don't want to i don't
want to be
selling down here because there's a big
buyer here okay so the market may not
make that move but when you see this
traded in the market
you know that's the beauty of looking at
a footprint chart is because
every trade that goes through the
exchange gets posted instantly so you're
going to see it
show up in the volume so once that
volume
trades you know that there was a big
buyer there you know and this is
different than say looking at a dome
or looking at um you know a book map
you know pokemax and bookmaps and domes
do have their place in trading
but what's more important actual
liquidity
that traded in the market as opposed to
resting liquidity
that is just there that you know is
acting sort of as as a
moving goal post okay you know once
someone commits themselves to the market
when someone buys 200 contracts in this
field that too you know
on 200 they got a position on and that's
different than someone that
trying to buy 200 you know half a buck
lower
right that mentality is different when
you have a position on as opposed to
when you don't you know it's just like
trading with
you know real money as opposed to sim
you know there's a different mentality
you know i would love to buy here at 20
24 and a half you know i'll put a
thousand lots in there
but if the market's not going to go
there it doesn't mean anything
you know but when the 200 lots trade at
it means something especially when the
market reacts off of it
now like i said the volume footprint
chart
is the best in my opinion for seeing
what the big boys are doing
because you can see the volume that is
being traded
and as much as the big boys want to
remain hidden in the background they
cannot hide
what they actually trade in the market
because like i said
you know once they trade in the market
on the screen
it shows up there for everybody to see
so knowing
where and when the big traders are
active in the market gives you
insight into the market other traders
just don't have you know if you're
looking at a normal bar chart
you're not going to see the volume
that's being traded
and the volume plays an important role
as much as a lot of people like to
discount the volume
it does matter you know think about it
right if you've ever
run a business you know a brick and
mortar business selling
anything you're going to check your
sales numbers
right you don't just check what you sell
at a price you're going to check what
you sell
the quantity at a price say you sell
um you know say you sell jackets okay
you price it a certain price right and
then you raise the price you raise the
price
as as demand comes in it gets to a
certain point where
there's no more demand because your
price is so high so you guys start
lowering the price
so you check you know the quantity that
you sell at each price and it's the same
thing in the market
now the next part that i want to talk
about is getting the maximum out of
order flow delta
now we're all familiar with the trading
dome
right it shows you know the market depth
to the upside to the downside
and where the current bid offer is but
order flow is
is really about understanding what the
aggressive traders are doing in the
market
and what is an aggressive trader it's
someone that crosses the bid offer
to trade so in this case
you know here's the s ps it's 33
39 bit at 39 and a quarter okay size of
78 by 98
and then below it you got bids at 38 and
three quarters 38 and a half above you
got
offers at 39 and a half or 39.75
so people that are sitting on the bid
are what you call passive buyers people
sitting on the offer
are what you call passive sellers so for
a trade to happen
a passive buyer has to become aggressive
right they have to cross
the bid offer line they have to go from
33 39
to pay the offer at 39 and a quarter
that's what you call an aggressive buyer
for someone to be considered an
aggressive seller
they have to sell they have to move
their offer down from 39 and a quarter
to 39 right they are aggressively
selling
and think of it like this if you're out
you know if you're buying a house okay
you see a house you like it's a quarter
of a million dollars
but you're like yeah yeah uh you know it
needs a new paint job it needs a new
driveway i'll i'll give you 235 thousand
dollars
well the buyer's like well you know i'm
just trying to sell it at 250 000.
so you're not going to get a trade done
right you want to pay 235
the guy wants to sell it at 235 one of
you is going to have to get aggressive
one you're either going to have to raise
your bid or the seller is going to have
to
lower his offer and hit your bid but if
the seller's like oh my gosh you know i
i gotta i got to sell this house okay
fine i'll sell it to you at 235
then the house seller is the aggressive
seller
right because he's moving down his offer
he's hitting your bid
because he wants to unload the house he
wants to get it off his hands
now if you're like oh my gosh my wife
really likes this house but
um you know i don't want to tell them so
you know i'll just say okay i'll buy
your house
250k i'll pay cash all right so you've
become
the aggressive buyer you know so when
you really want to get something a
transaction done you become aggressive
so you're gonna become aggressive seller
or an aggressive buyer
now order flow delta is a net difference
between aggressive buyer and aggressive
sellers in a bar
and just about all order flow traders
look at delta you know it's one of the
main cornerstone
cornerstones of order flow
is the delta information you know
because they want to know who
is in control of the market but within
order flow delta
there are different measures of delta
a trader can use to understand what's
happening in the market right now so
there's the delta
okay there's the max delta min delta and
there's cumulative delta
so there's actually within delta there's
additional subsets
of data so delta is the most commonly
used delta it's sort of like the the
headline number it's going to give you a
quick determination
of who's in control aggressive buyers or
aggressive sellers
all right so on a footprint chart
it'll appear generally it'll appear at
the bottom you know some people got
their own software that
will print it above or below a chart but
yeah
i think it's best along the bottom um
you know because you want to know where
it is at any given point in time and
it's just easier to keep it there but it
gives you a quick determination of who's
in control
and more importantly you can see
when the market is weakening or when the
market is strengthening
so what you have here in this case right
you see there or the little blue arrow
is you got a delta of 61.
so as the market is going up
you know it's coming up sort of making
this little swing high here right you
can see the delta is 238 then 123 then
61 at the blue arrow
and then minus 242 minus 115
minus 200. so as you're coming up into
the swing high this little mini swing
high
delta's getting weaker right remember
it's the difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers
so if you have a positive delta it tells
you aggressive buyers are in control
if you have a negative delta tells you
aggressive sellers are in control
but as you're going up into a high
you want to be seeing a more aggressive
buying you want to see the aggressive
buying getting stronger if the market's
going to continue higher
but as you're going up it's starting to
flatten
it's gone 238 to 123 to 61 and you can
see how the market is going sideways
then it becomes negative 242. now
sellers are in control
you're at your swing high but sellers
are in control well that's not a good
sign in the market right if the sellers
are in control
if you're at a swing high if you trade
momentum right you're thinking well the
market's going to go
higher but what's stopping the market is
the aggressive sellers now the market
starts turning aggressive sellers and
it's minus 242.
next is -115 you pop up here you make a
new high by
um a tick and you still got negative
delta you saw you're at a new high
with still negative delta what do you
think the market's going to do you think
it's going to go higher
you know people are trying to think i
should buy this breakout because we just
made a new high
by a tick over the previous high okay
well if you're looking at the order flow
specifically in the delta it's going to
keep you off that trade because
you can tell that aggressive sellers are
in control by looking at the delta
and then what happens you sort of go
sideways a little bit
but you still got the aggressive selling
coming in and boom the market drops
um a quick eight points in the next um
five minutes you know that's how you can
use delta in your trading
so remember delta is the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers now
max delta just deals with the aggressive
buying in the bar
and it's going to appear it's a
different number it'll appear
separate from the delta and what it is
it tells you how strong the aggressive
buying was
okay so if you see a number it's always
going to be a positive number because
it's aggressive buying so everything you
know when you have aggressive buying it
registers as plus one
so it can never be negative if it's
negative that will go under min delta
that would be aggressive selling
but when you see a number in the max
delta
what that tells you is how strong the
delta was at one point so you can see
cases where um you know
for example right here at 1240 the final
delta was 61.
max delta was 124. so
looking at those numbers what you take
away from it is at one point
aggressive buying was 124 but we only
settled at 61. so there was some
aggressive selling that came in to push
it back down
okay now the next bar
right here at 1241 had max delta of just
32.
but it finished with final delta of
minus 200
so i was telling you early in that bar
there was a little bit of aggressive
buying
not a whole lot because it was only
positive 32
but aggressive sellers took over in that
bar and
dominated that bar we closed at minus
242.
now there's times like you can see a
little bit earlier
around 1238 max delta was 238 final
delta was 238 so we closed on
our strongest delta reading in the bar
now there's going to be i don't have one
here but there's there's times where it
could be zero
okay that's the lowest it could be
meaning at no point where aggressive
buyers in control of the bar
now min delta is the opposite it shows
how strong aggressive selling was in the
bar
at one point so
you can see here around 1237
you had a min delta of minus one
okay what does that tell you says
aggressive selling was
never in control of the mark of that bar
you know because minus one
is you know one contract away from zero
which is you know the the weakest it
could be
but then you can see there's other cases
here where you know right
before this blue arrow down see mac min
delta was minus
117 final delta closed at minus
115 so we closed almost right on our
extreme
min delta meaning you know aggressive
sellers
were definitely in control of that bar
especially late in that bar
and it's important to understand you
know when aggressive buyers
or aggressive sellers are in control of
a bar
early or late especially if you're
trading on a
you know a time based chart because you
can see in the next bar it's going to
spill over
right because you know if you're trading
on a time-based chart let's say a
one-minute chart
well after 60 seconds the part just
automatically closes
right so if you got selling coming in
late in that bar
you know in the last five seconds of
that bar it often spills over
into the next bar and continues on in
the next bar
and you can see on the next bar had a
minus
min delta minus 273 final delta of minus
and there's a big red candle down okay
so
you know there's ways you can interpret
this delta which i'm going to get into
in a minute
um max and min delta and put together a
trading plan
now cumulative delta is
the total delta up to a point in time
from the open
right increases or decreases based on
each bar's delta
actually sorry i got the wrong box there
but it's the one that says
delta underneath and
you can see as it's each delta reading
um the next bar you know you minus or
subtract
the final delta from the cumulative
delta so you can see
you know we're right here at 1240
it had a cumulative delta of 5542 then
the next bar had a
the final delta of minus 242 so you
subtract the minus 242 from the
5542 that gives you a cumulative delta
in that bar at 1241
of 5 300. now there's ways you can use
cumulative delta
as well to help you understand market
direction
now advanced overflow traders look at
the relationships between max delta
and min delta in relation to each other
as well as relation
to the market context right you always
got to be trading in market context
and what i want to show you is how to
use max delta min delta and cumulative
delta to find an edge
all right so here we got max delta min
delta relationships
okay so you can see you know this market
comes down and makes a swing low
now at the swing low so
you got this big red bar down pushing
into the swing low
and you got big negative delta minus
min delta is minus 1138 then you hit the
swing low
you got positive delta early in this bar
mid delta was -319
but we closed the final delta at plus
positive 373.
max delta was 393. so what happened
well internally in this bar
you can see the shift from aggressive
selling to aggressive buying
very strong aggressive selling early min
delta minus 319
max delta 393 we closed at 373 in the
delta
so what's that telling you aggressive
you know there's aggressive selling
early
but aggressive buying late we close
almost on our highest
level in aggressive buying in the max
delta okay so
maybe you're not convinced then the next
bar after this low
min delta is only minus three that's
nothing
my that's that's nothing max delta was
final delta 246. so we're closing we had
very little aggressive
selling in that bar at you know so
aggressive sellers weren't really in
control of that bar at any point
and we're closing up near our max delta
number of 309
you know we're at 246. you know we're
closing a healthy positive delta
say you're still not convinced look at
the next bar it's minus one
min delta max delta is eight hundred
final delta is six one four so again
aggressive buyers definitely in control
obviously you got some buying and
balances in there which i'll get into
later
um yeah again yeah i'm not hiking i'm
still not convinced you know this order
flow stuff doesn't really
drive with me okay then you see the next
bar
it's mid delta minus 600. oh my gosh
mike you know
he's got a big negative delta max delta
zero
final delta is 308 okay now this is one
of the nuances i want to talk about
so what you have here is a green bar you
have this green candle
four bars off the low strong negative
delta
no max delta strong min delta
what's that telling you people if you're
just looking at the delta by itself this
is again why i talk about taking things
in context of the market
people say well you got aggressive
sellers are in control but the bar
was green so what's happened price
action in the bar
is positive delta is negative okay
so think about it for a second why
is the delta negative well you have
aggressive selling
okay well who are the aggressive sellers
selling to well the passive buyers
okay did the bar close up or down it
closed higher
so as we started rallying up
you've all of a sudden got passive
buyers coming in and supporting the
market
because you have aggressive sellers
selling into those bids
but the bids are strong enough to
support this market that's why you have
the negative delta
you know you got minus 608 so at one
point people like ah sell it sell it you
know market's going lower we're going to
break
29 but there's some a big buyer stepped
into the market and said you know
not on my watch not here you know
they're happy to buy it here around the
31 32 area
they're supporting that market all right
so
all the aggressive selling that's coming
in
is being absorbed by the passive buyers
this is a sign of absorption in the
market even though
you know the market does tick up closes
higher you still got the
negative delta people say oh you know we
got the negative delta the big negative
delta
you know i don't think we're going
higher this is recognizing what
absorption
is in the market then the next bar
at 926 0 min delta
max delta 729 final delta
718. if you're not convinced by this bar
you might as well give up trading you
know this
previous bar here at 925 is a clear sign
of absorption
and earlier you saw the aggressive
buying coming in and as you come out of
the absorption you see the aggressive
buying take over
and the market rallies 10 more points
off of that
so you got you know that's one of the
things you got to understand just
because you have a negative
delta or a positive delta take it in
context with what's happening in the bar
be able to understand the aggressive
buying and the aggressive selling
to the passive buyers to the passive
sellers
okay here's more on the max min delta
relationships
okay so we hit this new low again all
these charts are just from yesterday
okay and we're coming into this low
we're selling off selling off make the
new low at uh
124 125
126 another new low okay
and as you're coming down making the low
at 923 924
strong negative delta no max delta at
all zero and zero
on those two bars coming into those two
red bars coming into the low
all mac all men delta right
close at min delta numbers first one
minus 965
min delta was minus 1008 the next bar
um the min delta is minus 969
final delta is minus 629 so it's a
little bit weaker you know not much but
a little bit and then you hit you pair
up the low
double bottom here minus 190.
so you didn't have the big strong
aggressive selling that you had earlier
with the minus 1 000 minus 969
then it turns positive delta 618 max
delta we closed at 583 so we're closing
right there around our
strongest delta point in the bar
then the next bar okay it's kind of a
mix it's kind of a wash
right you get min delta minus 140 max
delta 100
okay pretty evenly distributed
final delta 21 which is small you know
it's
for me if a delta in a bar is around 50
or less i treat it as neutral
in terms of market analysis
then the next bar where's the aggressive
selling it's minus 13 only that's
nothing
max delta is 9 15 we close at 9 14 in
the delta
okay so one tick one contract off our
max delta number
so you know the aggressive buyers are
coming in here then what happens
you know it's the market it goes
sideways on you and it tests the low
minus 400 min delta
final deltas minus 390. okay it's kind
of bearish
but we're still a bit higher um then the
next bar 14
on the delta which is a neutral number
again the
internal delta numbers are kind of mixed
228 versus minus 130.
then as we go sideways again 201
versus 129 and 239 so again kind of
mixed internally in the max and min
delta
then we get this bar we test the low
it's minus 785 early in the bar
and you know i'm thinking i'm along here
from 33 24.
oh my gosh you know we're trading two
and a quarter
looking at the min delta in this bar
it's minus 700 at one point so at one
point it's just all aggressive selling
but what happens something changes in
the bar went from minus 785 you close at
minus 77.
so you had imagine what happened 70 785
aggressive sellers over aggressive
buyers in the bar
but the aggressive buyers came back
wrestled control you know to sort of tie
it back up at
77 which is kind of a relatively small
number so he went from minus 700
to just 77. so it ate back about 700
contracts
and then the next bar is the the money
bar so to speak
are we going to see more aggressive
selling or more aggressive buying
and like i was saying earlier you know
on time-based charts especially
you know since it's based on concept of
time
you often see the spillover into the
next bar so you saw
some voracious buying late in this bar
all right as the min delta went from
minus 785
and we closed at just 77 in the delta
the bind spilled over into the next bar
and you can see the min delta is only 29
max delta 761 final delta 721 so we're
closing right on our right near our
max delta so you know buyers are
definitely in control
and then the market starts it's makes it
finally makes the move in the direction
from you know the 25 area up to the 30
area
so that's how you can use the max and
min delta
relationships to understand what's
happening in the market now the
cumulative delta
can be used to determine the market's
overall strength
so you know the way that a lot of
traders can use
cumulative delta is watch
sort of these turning points you know
this is a very basic way to use it
but you see cumulative delta as we come
into this low at
you know 125 126 delta's negative
okay yeah that's you know you expect it
to be negative
usually expect it to be its strongest
negative but you know granted
yesterday was um unemployment day so the
market's a bit
um all over the place
then it starts turning positive after
the low is made
you know that that's not a sign of a
market that
that really wants to go lower if you're
got a negative
delta going into the low then all of a
sudden boom it flips right on the low or
a bar or two after
three after the low aggressive buying is
coming in
you know you should be when you're going
into the low oftentimes it takes a lot
of selling pressure to get down to the
low so you're going to be a strong
negative delta if you're at the low
and the delta is just kind of you know
around break even you know around zero
that's not a good sign right and
especially you know if it can't hold its
its negativity so to speak that's again
not a good sign so we hit our low we got
positive 28 cumulative delta in the next
bar
come back down hit the low the next bar
positive delta next bar positive
delta and x bar positive delta what do
you think the market's going to be doing
you don't expect the market to keep
selling off you expect the market to
start to rally because
what you don't have now you don't have
the aggressive selling at the low of the
day
now another way people use it is you
know they compare
the cumulative delta where we are at one
point
earlier to where we are now especially
if we're at a high or
low and going sideways you know is it
strong or is it weak this is bonds
yesterday
and you can see as we come up we make
the swing high
delta's at 25 38 which you know you're
at a swing high
you expect a positive delta you can see
how it's positive delta it keeps growing
942 1000
1300 1965 2538 as you pop
up here okay then we go sideways
one two three four five six seven bars
this is a
five minute chart so it's about a half
hour just over a half hour
cumulative delta what's it doing
well now at this nine o'clock cumulative
delta is only
two thousand earlier was twenty five
hundred
we haven't we've gone one tick higher
than earlier
but mostly just gone sideways so what's
that telling you think about it for a
second
you're at 2500 cumulative delta
so earlier you had 2500
more aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers
then you hit a high and you go sideways
you're starting you know you put in some
time 30 minutes later you're still at
that same level
but your cumulative delta shrink from
2500 to 2000
okay so what's going to cause that mark
that
cumulative delta to shrink is aggressive
selling
and you can see obviously you can see
the delta is minus 244
minus 323 minus 224 minus 220
you know and you had a positive 68
positive 300 but
you think about it right accumulation
distribution
you're at your high level you know big
traders they don't want to move the
market so they're distributing they're
slowly distributing over this half hour
period
you know over 500 contracts net net
um they're selling it all right without
trying to move the market too much
then what happens the market finally
breaks and sells off from
you know that 182 16 all the way down to
you know the 18202 area but the signs
were there
in the cumulative delta as you're going
sideways
you could see the distribution going on
all right because you know as you're
going sideways you're going to start to
think well is this market going is this
just pausing
are they going to go higher or is it
pausing and then go lower
reading the delta cumulative delta tells
you
market is most likely going to go lower
someone's distributing
their their position up here they're
getting out of the position
or maybe they're initiating some shorts
again you don't know
all you care about is what's happening
in the order flow
right you could make that guesses okay
well
i don't see people building up a
position here instead i see people
lightening up their position or getting
short
so cumulative delta max delta min delta
are data points that give you further
insight into the market
that you may have overlooked or not
noticed right if you're not using order
flow
you're not going to see it now i'm going
to talk about imbalances because you
know imbalances
is a great tool for traders to
understand what's happening in the
market and a lot of traders
sort of miss the point on imbalances so
remember on our dome right you have
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
trading against each other
against the passive buyers and passive
sellers and imbalances occur
when there are more aggressive buyers
versus aggressive sellers in the two-way
auction okay so what that means is you
know here's
markets 39 even bid at 39 and a quarter
if one lot trades at 39
but 50 contracts trade at 39 and a
quarter you say there's
a buying imbalance because there's more
trading on the offer
there's more aggressive buying going on
so that would be considered a buying
imbalance
so while delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar
imbalances occur when there are more
aggressive buyers versus aggressive
sellers in the two-way auction
buy a ratio of four to one generally you
know some people use three to one some
people use
six to one some people use ten to one
but you know sort of the
general ratio that most people use is
four to one i use four to one
now not every bar or price level will
have an imbalance
in the two-way auction and on an order
flow chart
most order flow charts again you can
customize the colors but most people use
blue
and red you know red for selling blue
for buying and you can see i didn't
highlight all of them
but i highlighted um you know
i had a few so you can just sort of see
how it looks like on an order flow chart
so you can see where there's areas of
aggressive buying you know right off the
low of the day
or the low of this move rather you can
see some aggressive buying
nine against 87 155 against
uh 715 and you're going to see also some
sometimes you're going to see silent
balances in green bars just as you can
see buying and balancing
in blue bar in sorry in red bars
you can see here the selling of balance
on this green candle off the low 510
against 115
you know that's more than a four to one
ratio if you're using five to one ratio
it wouldn't show up
so again you know four to one is what
most people use and the one four to one
is
is a good starting point for a lot of
people i know some people like to get
fancy and use
you know 987 tawan um
you know honestly the difference between
987 to one and
a thousand to one which is ten to one is
13 contracts i don't think that makes
that big difference
in the analysis because you're sort of
trying to define it very tightly now
most order filtrators understand what
imbalances are why they occur
but now you got to apply them to the
market and stacked imbalances
is how most traders apply imbalances and
what the stacked imbalance is is when
there's three or more imbalances
stacked neatly on top of each other or
below each other so stack selling and
balance as you can see here on the left
167 against three 129 against 23
240 against zero
these are selling you know you got one
two three selling imbalances all stack
neatly on top of each other
over here you have three mining balances
one against 93 29 against 187
43 against 791
and they're all stacked neatly on top of
each other right one two three price
levels neatly stacked on top of each
other that's how most traders use
imbalances
um you know because having a single
imbalance in a bar
doesn't necessarily mean anything other
than you know what the liquidity was at
that time but when you start seeing
bunches of them in a bar
especially stacked on top of each other
it starts to it means something
you know it means a big order was coming
through the market you either had a big
aggressive buyer or
a big aggressive seller active in the
market at that point
a stop could have been triggered you
know there's several different meanings
in it and one of the
nuances which i'll just give this one to
you you know i sort of talk about this
in my inner circle is what i call an
overlapping imbalance right you got a
stackstone and balance followed by a
stack buying and balance
within a certain amount of bars it's
very
um bullish in this case
because you got the stacks on a bounce
on the way down but then buyers came in
stepped up
or within a certain amount of bars to
buy it back
realizing this low is
probably going to hold for now and
they're getting aggressive and they're
buying it up
this is what i call an overlapping
imbalance and
i talk about it in my my inner circle
and it's it's something you know you can
build a training plan around you know
you look for them in certain markets and
they're
quit quite uh quite nice trades to take
now
stack selling and balance again you know
it's very obvious
very optical right you can see it it's
very clear one two three
imbalances all stack neatly on top of
each other
and you know they work and sometimes
they don't work you know here's a stack
buying and balance
boom market shot up and then it came
right back down through it
okay this you know did it work yeah
technically you know it went up
but then it quickly came back down um
through the level
but i want to share with you strategies
that that work basically
and please note right market doesn't
trade in a bubble in the sense that you
should
look beyond what the bar right in front
of you is doing and understand what the
market is doing in general
is the market going up trending down
going sideways
you know you got to take everything in
market context right just because you
have a stack buying a balance
where is it occurring is the stack
buying and balance occurring off the low
right like here right you got a stack
selling a balance you had a trend down
then you got stacked selling a balance
well it's probably not going to be very
effective because you got to start
thinking about what's the capacity for
the market to move lower
but the market moved down now it's
starting to move up and you see a stack
buying a balance coming you see us that
aggressive buyers coming in off the low
you got to weight this more than this
just on
where it's coming in on the market
structure you got aggressive buying
coming in off the low
it's going to be more important than
aggressive selling coming in
after a protracted move down you know
what you could be having here is people
capitulation fear missing out fomo
coming in
oh my gosh we just sold off 10 points i
want to sell it and then
what happens they sell the low and the
market starts rallying what you want to
catch is
as you start coming up off the low is
there aggressive buying coming in
just as you look for aggressive selling
off a high
so that's why i say take things in
context
so what i want to share with you is
multiple imbalances
and you know i just talked about stacked
imbalances which is three or more
imbalances in a bar stack neatly on top
of each other
but you could have instances where you
have three or more buying and balances
or selling and balances in a bar
that aren't stacked neatly on top of
each other okay
they can be spread out in a bar you
could have two then a normal
price level with normal order flow then
another imbalance right that's what i
call a multiple
imbalance and as this was something that
was very important to me and i had it in
my software
for years already and you know there's
people telling me you know i just look
for these multiple imbalances
at certain points in the market you know
at swing highs or swing lows
and just trade it so you know earlier i
was showing you this example
right you had to stack buying and
balance that market went up then came
right back down
but earlier you see this bar it's got
the
purple box around it you have four
binding balances in here
four blue numbers one against nineteen
zero against six zero against twenty
eight
eight against 44. this is a bar with
multiple imbalances
so where would you rather get long here
at 117
94 or up here at 118.04
it's allowing you to get into this trade
it's recognizing aggressive buyers
earlier than just looking for the
stacked imbalance
so you get in a full 10 points you can
catch this move this is the move you
want
right you don't want the second move
with the stacked imbalance because it
only goes up then immediately it comes
back down
but even if you're buying it here at 94
at 95
even if you ride it all the way up comes
back down it only comes back down to
the 95 area before it starts going back
up to the 118 area
you know multiple imbalances are going
to help you
get into trades a lot earlier
so this as you can see here right the
multiple imbalances
in this bar right that's what you want
to see
now here's a move up
right you've got multiple imbalances
right off the swing low
right you go up you come pull back a
little bit more multiple
imbalances go back up pull back down
more multiple imbalances
again this is just yesterday afternoon
in the e-minis
it occurs over and over in the markets
right and if you're just looking for
stacked imbalances you don't see any on
this chart
right because they're spread out in a
bar
so you know you have to not rethink
imbalances you just got to add okay
common sense well
you know just because you have
imbalances in a bar
that are not stacked on top of each
other doesn't mean they're not important
they are important and you can see here
how it's giving you
one two three trades as the market is
rallying up
off the low now here's the market was
going sideways
right this is a bond okay this is
yesterday it's a five minute chart
you can see it's just going sideways and
boom aggressive selling coming in
you know if you trade breakouts and
people say well i don't need order flow
for that i could trade the breakout
well yeah wouldn't you want to know if
there's aggressive selling
in the bar and we sell off from you know
the the
182 0809 area
all the way down you know to new lows at
24.
here you go right more multiple
imbalances right this is e-minis right
markets going sideways
if you're only looking for stacked
imbalances you just miss this move
because there's no stacked imbalances
until
later right you can see up here earlier
around the the 3336 area
you got two bars with multiple
imbalances in them right then the market
sells off
sells off and then down here at 33 32
you got multiple imbalances
stacked and balanced rather but the move
already happened
right where would you rather be short
from the 36 area
or the 32 area yeah the market you know
this
second imbalance went down from you know
the 31 area down to the 29 area
okay that's two points you know you
probably would have expected to keep
going lower
if you didn't cover it the market came
right back up through your
stacked imbalance and probably would
have stopped you out but if you're short
from 36 you're getting into the trade
a heck of a lot earlier right you're
catching that
big move down rather than catching the
small move down
a little bit later and you know for
people that that
you know like to think the markets are
fractal look at this it's a e-mini
one-minute chart
you got this big sideways action to the
left before you got the stack selling uh
the multiple selling of balance right
earlier bonds same thing markets going
sideways here
and then boom multiple selling
imbalances as the market breaks down
just you know very similar that chart to
this chart
you know one's a this one's an e-mini
one-minute chart this is a bond
five-minute chart
you know the markets react the same way
because you know the big traders trade
the same way
you know they can't hide their size if
they want to get a position on they got
to start being aggressive at some point
you know they can only passively sell or
passively buy a certain amount
before the market starts moving but once
the market starts moving they got to get
aggressive
now multiple imbalances doesn't mean it
has to be three or more imbalances a bar
you could start at two all right if say
you trade i don't know
some people trade a hundred tick chart
you know you could use
look for two imbalances in a bar or say
you know you have bars let's say you
trade nasdaq right you could use four
because you know nasdaq can cover
a lot of price levels so for example
here's a
e-mini this is a four-range chart right
so it's a range based charts you only
get four
sorry five price levels in a bar but you
could see here like
boom to the left right
two imbalances market sells off hits the
swing low market starts rallying up
one two three bars with multiple
oh sorry two these are considered
multiple binary bounces because it's set
to two imbalances
one two one two one two then you got
three here okay
then another two mark goes sideways
starts
going sideways then you see aggressive
selling coming in
to the right you see two bars with two
sauna balances as the market
goes down so you can see us it's almost
doesn't always pick these exact turning
points like that but you know it's it's
pretty good
you know here's again e-mini's these all
just charged from yesterday
you know at the swing low market goes up
on the left they're
at 151 rallies up three points
comes back down boom rotates to 29 and a
half
rotates back up to 33. comes back down
to 31
multiple imbalances as the market goes
back up so you can just you know there's
so many ways
you can apply multiple imbalances to
your trading
now you know if you want to be you know
a bit more stricter
you can say well i just want to see bars
with four more imbalances in them
now you'll notice you see any stacked
imbalances here
no any stacked imbalances there no so if
you're looking
only for stacked imbalances you're
missing a lot of trading going on
right you're missing a lot of trading no
stacked imbalances there so this is a
bar it's a eight range
chart on the e-minis with
only with four imbalances or more you
can see here
it gives you this nice trade um right at
12 27.
you know markets it's a nice five-point
move up from
you know the 34 area all the way up to
the 40 area
you know it's just you don't see a lot
of you know depending on the chart
you know if you set your imbalance
levels to
four or five you might not see a lot
but the ones that you see can be
dynamite
you know here yesterday e-minis again
got our swing high start coming off
bar with strong aggressive selling four
selling imbalances
boom again the market makes its move
from you know the 40 area
down to 35. you know it's
it's it's beautiful sometimes so as you
just saw
you know there are more ways to look at
imbalances in a bar beyond just stacked
imbalances
so you know look at multiple imbalances
my order flows trader software will
highlight them to you if you're not
using my software say you got another
software
that has a footprint chart you just
gotta use your eyes you know i like to
have the software
highlight things to me and the order
flows traders does
now lastly i'll talk about short-term
value
how to determine it and how to trade it
so what's value
right well think of it as what
something's worth right that's why gold
is going up because it's a storage of
value
once you know what it's worth then you
know if its value is going up or its
value is going down
and understanding where value is
in where the market is trading in
relation to value is going to help you
when you're confused on what the market
is doing you know sometimes
you know honestly you know sometimes we
get in positions and it just it's not
really working out we feel a little bit
confused
you know this market should go higher
but it's not going higher or it should
go lower but it's not really going lower
well now you got to take a step back and
and think of where value is in the
market you know
order flow has a thing called point of
control
and it's the price level in the bar with
the most volume when you see
several point of controls at the same
level over consecutive bars
the market is often defining value okay
so
first of all point of control every bar
has one and
on a footprint chart it's going to be
you know there'll be like a rectangle
around that price level
but when you see points of control sort
of lining up in an
area you know over three bars or more
at the same price level the market is
sort of defining value in that area
because you know
over time people are trading at that
level a lot of volume
all right and that's important to
understand because when there's a lot of
volume trading at a specific level
that means traders are are happy to
transact at that at that level that's a
fair price to them
that's where the value is right now in
the market in the short term
but you got to watch what happens as you
start moving outside
of that bunch poc you know we got here
like i drew the
blue box around these three bars that
have plc's right at the same level okay
that's fine well you know maybe i was
long from earlier then the market's just
going sideways
what do i do well i see oh my gosh you
know we're putting in
bars with the same point of control okay
so we're going sideways
then you got to watch what's happened as
you start moving out of that area
that sideways activity and then you can
see the next bar it's got a higher point
of control
right the one right above the blue arrow
so the point of control is now higher
than it was earlier when you put the
three in
the next bar is higher next bar comes
back down to the previous one
then the next bars are higher so you
know you can feel confident in your
position
that we are trading starting to put in
value areas right the points of control
think of them as
value in that bar and when you have
several point controls at the same price
you know
it's putting in a bigger value area but
as each bar
happens you got a higher value area
and again you know here right you know
you're sort of thinking
you know maybe you're along from earlier
and it's just going sideways on you it's
frustrating you know sometimes we get
into these trades that frustrate us
and then you can see here in this blue
box all right i've got
four bars three of them have the same
price level
uh the same point of control so it's
putting in this value area there
then obviously we break down through it
which is not a good sign a lower point
of control
at this point if you are long and you
got to stop
you know somewhere down here around 33
34 you just got to get out
right don't expect the market to turn
around and start rallying
because traders found an area up here
they're happy to trade happy to transact
then the market comes off that area and
starts putting in lower points of
control
that's not a good sign because now
you're putting in lower value
to the value that you just had earlier
now another way to use point of controls
to help understand what the market is
doing is watching how they move
you know in a trend up when a control
suit migrate higher in a trend down
point of controls should migrate lower
and this is especially important as the
market starts breaking out of sideways
activity
so you can see here right you got market
sort of going sideways up here on the
top
left and then lower point of control on
this big red bar down
the blue bar or sorry the green bar got
a lower point of control the next red
bar lower point of control
next red bar lower point of control
opponent of controls are going lower
that's what you expect on a market
trending down
right so again if you're in a position
and you start seeing
lower points of control if you're short
that's good if you're
long and you start seeing bars put in
lower points of control
that's not a good sign the market is
finding lower value
over each bar
all right so again you know mark is sort
of going sideways in here chop chop chop
chop
and then you start seeing the methodical
move down in points of control
at 105. point of controls up here
next bar lower next red bar lower next
red bar lower next red bar lower
you know after after i start seeing
three points of control
move in a direction i start it's not in
the direction that i'm positioned and i
start to
reconsider being in that position so if
i'm long right say i'm
you know i'm long from whatever 31 then
i start seeing a point of control at 33
then 32 and a half then 31 and a half
i see three lower points of controls
that's not a good sign of that position
i know that i should really consider
cutting it chances are i'm probably
going to it's going to go
march right down to my stop and in this
case
the market marched down you know if you
had a stop down here at 29 you'd have
been stopped out
but if you can read what's happening in
the order flow as it
the points of control are migrating
lower
you get out you know 31 31 and a half 30
and a half
rather than taking the full loss at 29
you know and just wait for a better
opportunity you know everyone always
talks about
cutting your losses short i don't really
show you how to do that you know
by reading the order flow by reading the
points of control what's it doing by
reading the delta
what's that doing that's going to help
you cut your losses short because
you're going to recognize the market is
not doing what you
expect it to do based off your analysis
all right you can analyze the out
of it but
the market's going to do what it's going
to do and
no analysis you do is going to make the
market do what you want it to do
right so you got to read what's
happening in the market after you get
into a trade so here market's railing
right
points and controls are rallying up
right you got the three
right you got big three points of
controls right at the same level
then you start breaking out to the
upside you got multiple mine imbalances
obviously you got nice positive delta
nice strong
max delta you know everything you want
to see on a move going up
you got the stacked imbalance earlier
points of control
higher higher higher higher higher right
that's this is everything putting it
together right
values moving higher you got the
multiple imbalances right you have a
stacked imbalance down here at 927
and 30 seconds okay that's nice but
earlier
you had the bar at 927 with multiple
imbalances okay so again multiple
imbalances
often precede stacked imbalances
right and that's going to give you an
edge over other traders you see the
points of control migrating higher
after going sideways between 929 and 930
you see the positive delta appearing
there and you see
um max delta and min delta relationships
right you don't see
very strong min delta so you know the
aggressive selling is not that strong in
there
so once you start putting together the
different parts of order flow the market
just starts to make sense
you know and as so many people have
written to me afterwards saying you know
what
you know after following the order flow
understanding what i'm looking at i
really understand the markets now you
know and
that's what it trading is all about
right to be successful in the markets
you have to understand why something is
happening
why a move is happening why the move is
weakening why the move is strengthening
you know an order flow helps you
understand all that
information and understand when when
the market is in its different phases
right and orderful analysis provides the
trader
the information they need to gain an
edge over other traders you know a lot
of this information
you're not going to see on a normal bar
chart okay
so you want to see and understand what's
happening in the market that other
traders
don't see right that other traders
aren't looking at so hopefully you can
see how powerful order flow
analysis is right you don't want to over
complicate trading you know traders like
to overcomplicate things you know throw
different indicators at the market and
hopefully something sticks right
just learn to trade trade what's
happening right in front of you
right and you know there's you know the
famous
saying i always laugh when i was younger
my dad told me
this saying um you know the famous
english actor
sir john gilgood um was in a movie with
uh dustin hoffman
you know dustin hoffman's a method actor
and he's going through all this thing
i got to get into the character and i
got to do all this stuff
and john gilgot says why don't you just
act you know it's the same thing with
traders right oh i got to add this
indicator i got to trade you know i got
to put this indicator on i got to put
this up
why don't you just trade the market just
trade you know it's the same thing
so if you found this presentation
helpful and hopefully you did
you'll like my order flows trader
software package which makes orderful
analysis
easy so you know hopefully you're ready
to add order for analysis to your
trading
so there's two ways to do it one the
first way is try and learn order flow on
your own
okay you can spend years of looking at a
screen trying to figure out order flow
more importantly you're going to waste
years of time and money
trading thinking you understand it when
you really don't understand it
you know i was very fortunate you know i
i worked in big commodity trading firms
i've worked for banks
so i was daily exposed to many different
traders and different trading
mentalities i was able to
take things you know but in
conversations with traders what works
for them
you know just talking about markets and
analysis and i've
cultivated my method of trading over
many years
by dealing with successful traders right
so the second way is
that way get the education and software
from a trader who has successfully
traded order flow at the highest level
for decades you know i've traded
professionally for you know 25 years
okay so i i know what i'm doing you know
i'm confident in what i'm doing
this is how i support myself skip the
massive trading losses
skip the wasted time you know get the
proper education
not only that get the proper software
right order flow is the most current
information available to a trader it's
not some indicator
it's the market right you gotta trade
the market don't trade an indicator
order flow is not based on pivot levels
it's not fibonacci it's not based on
elliott wave
it's not based on macd it's not based on
vwab or anything like that
your order flows what's trading on the
bid what's traded on the offer
order flow is the market so the order
flows trader now it runs on ninjatrader
eight it doesn't run
on trade of eight it doesn't run on
tradestation it runs on ninjatrader
eight it'll run on the free version as
well
i got a lot of people that use the free
version and just use a different trading
front
and to enter the orders and it's the
volume footprint chart that you saw
in this presentation right the charts
are generated from the order flows
trader software
so you can see like the multiple
imbalances you can see the points of
control you can see all that information
you're also going to get my chart
template normally i sell this for 8.99
okay but i realize having order flow
software is one thing
you got to know how to use it so i don't
just give you the software and send you
on your way i provide a lot of education
on how to trade with order flow and each
week
i do a private live group training
session for users
if you can't attend you could watch the
recording and i got over
80 80 recordings you know some people
could charge extra for this it's free i
write it for free you can ask questions
say you're stuck on something so you
want to
you know look at a particular market
every tuesday night i've been on
vacation for the last two weeks so i
haven't had the sessions
but you know i'm starting up again on
the 11th
and again you know it's free it's a
resource for you it's a resource to
reach out to me you'll say you know
oh mike you missed my email sometimes
emails go to spam you can ask your
question in this trading room and it's
every
tuesday night 7 p.m to about 8 p.m
central time okay and it's free it's a
free resource for you you can watch the
recordings if you can't attend
i will also give you the order flows
trading course which
is the first course i did on order flow
trading and normally i sell it for 297
and you know people buy it every day on
my website for 297. you can get it for
free
but i realize you know a lot of people
sort of understand the basics of order
flow and they want more advanced stuff
so let me give you also
access to my order flow inner circle
series this is the videos there's 56
videos on advanced order flow
tricks tips analysis and nuances
normally i sell this video collection by
itself
for almost 500 497. i'm going to give
you that
also for free so when you add up
the software all the different trainings
you know it's
comes out to about 1700 1693
okay but think of it this way
it's like skipping the line at disney
world right trying to figure out order
flow
by yourself is like standing in line
trying to get into disney world
trying to get into that ride you know
what you want to do is you want mickey
mouse to come out
not a mickey mouse you want mickey mouse
come on say hey you you know
hey joe come to the front of the line
come over to our secret entrance so to
speak
and you know fast track yourself so to
and as a special bonus for investors
expo users
visitors rather i'll give you access to
my order flow playbook
right which is a course i did on
order flow it's it's a great course you
know there's a lot of great trade setups
in there that i discuss
i'll give you that for free normally i
sell it for 297.
so you know you're pushing already close
to two thousand dollars and that's not
even including
what other people charge for like the
weekly group training
but you're not going to pay that right i
don't want you to pay so much you know
because you know money is tight for a
lot of people
you know but other people have bought my
software i said this is what they say
about it
you know your order flows software is
remarkably helpful i can clearly see now
who's
what is really happening in the market
like who's in control the market on a
very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well you know another
guy writes um
order flow is the path forward and
mike's experience an explanation
and it clicks okay so think about it
right you want to be successful in
trading
you got to figure out how you're going
to get there oftentimes you're not going
to get there
by yourself right you're going to need
some education so
for a one-time payment of 6.75
there's no monthly payments or any other
payment
in the future you know of course you're
going to need to pay your data fees for
the exchange data the live data
ninja trader fees if if you have a
paid version of ninjatrader but the
software will work on the free version
just go to orderflows.com2.html
okay and it's going to take you to this
page just scroll down to the bottom of
the page
this is the page at orderflows.com off
to two
it's gonna take you to this button just
click
buy buy now you know i want this right
it's gonna take you to paypal
okay i don't process your card paypal
does
okay if you don't you have paypal most
people have paypal
the button right below it says pay with
a debit or credit card that will allow
you to pay
without having a paypal account
now if you want my book okay
um you can see here go to
orderflows.combook.html
and you'll have to enter your name and
email address
okay then after you hit submit it will
take you directly to the download page
that you can download the book from okay
it'll pop up as a
new window so it's not going to pop up
on the same window that you enter your
information
and you can save it to your computer
print it up save it to your handphone
save it to your tablet whatever
um you know it's there for use as as a
resource so
you know to get started you got to get
started you know with anything in life
you got to take action you know that's
that's the worst thing is
you know people i see a lot of people
come to me mike you know i want to be
a trader okay what are you doing to
start trading
and they have no plan they they have no
uh what do you want to call it no no way
to become successful they just think
that they're gonna
open up an account and start trading and
you know money's just gonna magically
fall from the sky
you know it no it's not you know you got
to
take action you got to learn what you
want to do in life right we all not
going to be a doctor
and just also oh i'm going to read a
book on on becoming a doctor and become
a doctor in the next week
no you know you got to apply yourself
you got to learn how to become
you know a doctor you know trading you
got to learn how to read the markets you
got to learn to understand
what's happening in the market so again
you know
you've got to take action in life you
know the
honestly you know i i probably shouldn't
say this but
you know the biggest failures in life
are the people that
don't take action um in in life and
it's sad because you know i i know a lot
of i have friends that you know just
like
yeah mike um i want to do what you're
doing you know i want to trade
like you but then you know they don't do
anything to
take that next step forward right i say
yeah sure you know come on you know
let's let's work together oh i'm busy
that weekend or
um you know i i can't i got to get
another computer i got to do this well
gosh you know you could buy computers
are so cheap nowadays
um it's so easy to get a computer you
know
there's ways to do things cheaply and
everyone
you know stop making excuses in life
right you got to
take action and and do things you know
there's a phrase imperfect action
you know i'd rather you take imperfect
action at least get started doing
something
and then not take action and doing
something all right
and you know so there's you can become
successful as successful as you want to
be
right but the choice is yours so um
anyway
go to my website you know orderflows.com
off to you know if if you want to learn
a lot about order flow
go to my youtube channel subscribe to my
youtube channel i've got you know 250
some videos
on order flow up there you can learn a
lot you know that's
the easiest way and the freeway
to learn how to read order flow you know
watch what i have out there
already for free decide for yourself if
order flow
is for you so again
um if you're interested go to
orderflows.com
and you know get started take action
take charge of your life
so i'm going to end it there um you know
everyone that stuck around thank you for
coming in on saturday morning i realize
it's uh
it's a weekend but you know hopefully
you come away and you can learn a lot
about order flow
so have a great weekend everybody and
i'll see you guys on the inside
bye
you